we're asked how many inches are in four
and a half yards let me write that down
four and 1/2 yards now whenever we're
dealing with fractions and we're going
to multiply and divide by fractions it
really complicates the issue to have a
mixed number so right from the get-go I
want to turn this into an improper
fraction let me do it in over here in
the top right 4 and 1/2 written as an
improper fraction is equal to what we're
still going to have 2 as a denominator
so 2 times 4 is 8 so 8 halves is the
same thing as 4 right let me rewrite
this this 4 just as a bit of review 4 is
the same thing as 8 over 2 that's the
same thing as 4 and then you have that
plus plus 1/2 that is going to give you
9 halves the quick way to do it 2 times
4 is 8 8 plus 1 is 9 so 4 and a half is
the same thing as 9 halves so 4 and 1/2
yards is the same thing as let me write
it over here 9 over 2 9 over 2 yards now
we want to convert this into inches now
just so we can take this in baby steps
maybe we convert this into feet first
and then once we have it in feet then we
can convert it into inches so to convert
it into feet we just have to remember
that there are three feet for every one
yard so let me write that down there are
there are three feet there are 3 feet
per yard and if we were to multiply 9
halves yards times 3 feet this yard
would be in the numerator and be divided
by this yard and they would cancel out
and we just be left with feet so we know
we have to multiply by 3 you could say
this is 3 feet for every one yard if it
makes it simpler just 3 feet per yard
and another way to think about it is
however many yards you have you're going
to have more feet right there are 3 feet
per yard so if I have 1 yard I'm gonna
have 3 feet if I'm gonna have 2 yards
I'm gonna have 6 feet so you should
think about it in your head ok well yeah
multiplying by 3 so that also makes
sense so if we multiply by 3 right over
here
the nine times three is twenty-seven
over two over two times let me write it
out let me take it step by step not
skipping any steps so this is equal to 9
over 2 times 3 over 1 times 3 over 1
yards this yards right here I'll do it
in orange yards times feet per yards
feet per yard times in this purple feet
per yard the yards cancel out and you
are left with 9 times 3 is equal to 27
27 over 2 27 over 2 feet so we figured
out 4 and 1/2 yards is 27 over 2 feet
and that makes sense because we should
have more feet than yards and actually
this should be 3 times more so
everything makes sense this 27 over 2 is
3 times 9 over 2 so now we have 27 over
2 feet feet and now we want to convert
this to inches and we just have to
remember they're 12 inches per yard and
we're going to want to multiply by 12
because however many inches we have area
however many feet we have we're gonna
have 12 times as many inches if we have
one foot we're gonna have 12 inches 2
feet 24 inches 27 over 2 feet we're
going to multiply it by 12 to get the
number of inches so this is going to be
times 12 and we'll make sure the the
dimensions work out 12 inches 12 inches
per foot and the feet on the foot day
this is just the plural and the singular
of the same word it's the same dimension
this will cancel out so this will be if
we just rearrange the multiplication
view it as everything is getting
multiplied and when you just multiply a
bunch of things order doesn't matter so
this is equal to 27 over 2 times 12
times 12 feet I'm just swapping the
order feet times inches
inches / feet or foot just the singular
of the same word the feet and the foot
cancel out they're the same unit and you
have 27 times 12 divided by 2 inches and
what we could do here is that our final
answer is going to be our final answer
is going to be 27 times 12 over 2 inches
and before we multiply the 27 times 12
and then divide by 2 you immediately see
well I can just divide 12 by 2 and 2 by
2 and it makes our computation simpler
12 divided by 2 is 6 2 divided by 2 is 1
so it becomes 27 times 6 inches and
let's figure out what that is 27 27
times 6 7 times 6 is 42 2 times 6 is 12
plus 4 is 16 so it's equal to this is
equal to 162 162 inches which makes
sense 4 and 1/2 yards that gets us to
this number right here 27 divided by 2
is 13 and 1/2 feet you multiply that by
12 that makes sense you're gonna have a
bunch of inches 162 inches